the secret to playing poker is to be
super super rich and not care if you
lose I hope no real poker players are
watching this you have some kind of
disclaimer up right like if you enjoy a
poker and appreciate the game and have
any kind of respect for the game do not
watch what you're about to watch wonder
what are you doing
does everybody know how to play poker by
the way no that's no one no and you do I
mean like I know of what poll dude don't
[ __ ] do this to know this is Bobby
doing a bit now he doesn't want to talk
to me Robert do you know how to play
this is freshman guys are condescending
[ __ ] let me say two something do you
read okay I'm not playing your game this
show is this your single or you want his
single for that I would double what I
have a double with the skinny guy that's
a fat guys ok put an s on that yeah
piece of [ __ ] we're off to a good start
Tim listen you're both fat hey red
you're so disrespectful
I know buddy red what um I would I did
the pilot for this oh you did it behind
it is so so deal the cards that cuz
that's why it's taking so long for it to
get picked up smartass cameras good we
know without we have to reset all don't
reset it because come on this is just
like your mom picking up money off don't
know I was in an outburst but he started
he did he did one for first question
okay is are you pretending to be Bill
burr
I am I would like 15 years ago when he
had thanks for your help thank you
you're good this is the money and the
winner gets 150 and the second place
person gets 50 and the other two people
don't get [ __ ] okay right we really
gonna get this money yes these black
ones they're not worth anything so don't
bet with them oh you do the joke from
earlier is that what you're gonna do
because the cameras were uh-huh wait
notice how there's no yellow ones here
you notice they all be worthless so
first of all the whites are one the boys
are two the blacks are five green is ten
okay I have no idea somebody asked me to
be in can you leave the why just one
okay this is gonna it's gonna be all day
by the way you keep up that attitude
with me it's gonna be all for what I do
okay so a big blind in a small blind you
know what that is okay somebody else
Harry black can see that they don't
undersell can you do now it came to
somebody do it thank you
why don't we cut this part out this
supposed to be fun I might get a drink
get a drink yeah at this point ah give
me your jewel but I chew on the tips
though
what do you feel nothing is this
nicotine oh I shouldn't be drinking at
this point in the day but I guess
whatever it crackles yeah yeah toxic
chemicals kids do not do that in
staccato pencil and I feel
[Laughter]
we get the chips am i doing up good to
put the initial bed in alright that's
for the pot one the big blind the big
blind is 2 and the small blind is 1 ok I
think I know a little bit more about
poker than I let on I think I feel like
you're a [ __ ] card shark I play
professional poker 429 this is gonna be
good
I have a real question I went over there
get a drink did you get up because you
had to fart Bobby because it smells like
[ __ ] in here for real I feel like it I
don't smell it and now I feel like oh
you will you and I are friends right
yeah if you don't call that [ __ ] out it
everyone can smell it people watching it
on YouTube what the [ __ ] this is going
can't [ __ ] it smell it
now they got the next technology these
cameras are fogged up they have to
[ __ ] times it's not it's like watch
and Smith don't you know when you fart
you gotta then make a lap or further
away for 47 years we don't have the card
camp now let's put in one if I decide to
stay and I do to whites or one or one
blue if you want to stay in oh snap
you're raising off the bat no you don't
want to do I thought you said one blown
return oh yeah go ahead sorry I'm out
burn one okay does that help anybody is
two aces good two aces is who did you
had them it would be yeah I'm also out
you know so we can raise or something
you can what's called check check [ __ ]
which means that you don't put anything
and then the next person can check but
or you can race I can see so ministry
cards Bobby would
you checkmate when you're playing chess
with an old Russian guy that being said
feel free to submit whatever you want
I'm fine well I'm coming to more all
right Bobby see you there massa
- are you fold so play if you want to
yes you do you don't even own the next
two car but yeah then you have two more
cards to match them with these cards
what if it's the greatest card you need
okay so let's see oh [ __ ] so are you
gonna bet you can check or bet oh Jesus
- oh goodness I see your - and and I
raise you a black Oh
that's black is five five five bucks you
want to say it give me what I need shut
your mouth yeah dude you had two tens
I had nine tens you can now either bet
again right or you say show him sure but
then he has a chance but again right
yeah I think both wait this is the first
one don't go crazy here all right just a
whisper so I have two sixes what do you
got Bobby three that's it how's it feel
to get whooped on the first one Bobby
well we know we know exactly how you
guys
there was a lot of competition today at
the at the poker table Nikki was the
strongest by far not physically I will
beat her physically without a doubt
because she has that like what you know
but she probably has played before won
many pots so my greatest strength in
this game is that I've ever played
before at all Bobby Lee spent the
majority of the time passing gas which
is par for the course that fart smelled
like there was something a Bruin
something deep deep within him is wrong
not a very good poker player didn't know
any of the rules and cheated a bunch I'm
a deceitful one achieve I cheat all my
life you'll invite me back and guess
what I'll cheat again and guess what
there's nothing you can do about it my
poker skills are below novice whatever
one step below novice would be child
Andrew had an advantage because he knows
how to play poker and I think the rest
of us had a disadvantage because half
the time we weren't playing with the
right amount of cards you know you know
redheads you know they come they coming
with that redhead confidence Eric
Griffin grift of McGriff met him eight
minutes ago love them with all my heart
I don't get poker is when I play I just
want to go my poker face you know the
fat black I [ __ ] that guy correct yep oh
I'm big you're a little thank you do you
think I know poker players watch this
and just as so annoyed by yourself yeah
throat [ __ ] any basic knowledge of the
game you're gonna have a frustrating
time watching this right so I say you
either say you're gonna check to Bobby
so Bobby if you were going to play you
have to put in one more do you want to
play yes so there we go that's how it
goes now Griff you either you either
play two chips or you fold and you're
out oh I have to do all gotcha okay I'm
out right on okay
who's two are those um those that was
mine from the last time so whoever won
last time you did those I didn't take em
don't give those are yours we should
just burn $1,000
and now ideal cards right not will you
burn and then do the flop and then one
two three those are the three that I
needed the most
check Bobby's out crypts you're next
time cuz you have nothing to lose by
checking I got nothing but I know but
like you have nothing you there's no way
to win a bit to thank you Oh see I don't
know if you're just that's part end and
you really know how to play poker just
move on this is five commedia I'm gonna
stay in attending how to play I'm gonna
stay in for television oh yeah look at
this alright let's have some fun then
flop it well that's um check huh are you
thinking about if she can do that or if
you I'm just thinking of someone farted
again because it smells again and I'm
being dead I'm being genuine and you're
smiling at me which I know you means you
don't know why not smelling me it's he's
also here it's like you're throwing it
at me because you know that I'm annoyed
I am by it before me is there no way you
don't smell do you smell this
Kimi's look at this money aim for I
definitely think you can see a sign me
is that a special skill on the resume
all right let's see that oh I'm kind of
glad I stayed out that's fine that's I'm
not gonna say that's been nothing
nothing you should literally work I've
known here for years
you're gonna regret not betting okay
yeah I fall it's okay take it well
you're not gonna show huh of course not
oh wow that's a poker move
this rated as a poker game on a scale of
like a bunch of guys drinking beer
playing poker at their home to like the
World Poker Tour the WPT this is pretty
close to the World Poker Tour I feel
like this is almost identical this poker
game was worthless in terms of skill
rule-abiding anytime somebody's got to
ask like hey what beats a pair you know
then you're you're not gonna we're not
at a high level right now if a real
poker player watched us I think they
might die I think a professional poker
player would see this and feel the same
as me watching a professional poker
player do comedy but I'd watch the [ __ ]
out of it
Bobby farted all over the entire concept
and art and sport of poker playing it
has been soiled after today's gameplay
if you want to even call it gameplay
neither gain nor play are fitting words
for what happened here today there's my
favorite thing to do program where
people ask me to shuffle just like guys
you know like everyone's talking and
we're just doing anything makes a sound
makes a poker sound I'm impressed
someone needs to shuffle why do I have
to play oh wow guys Bobby does this
change anything for you what's do you
say ok you could check check check
alright and you gotta be careful what
the cards do they can see tech coming ok
3 fault
you're still in ok oh three oh three one
here's the last one
you're outta ok [ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ]
hey hey calm down check or you keep
don't be out just check you have to
check will he check so I'm gonna check I
can't
what do you have nothing nothing I have
two fives fives okay take that pot nice
we talked a little bit off-camera but
will you plug your show because out on
time when does come show will be
canceled way before this oh boy I don't
[ __ ] look at me something came out
don't look at me Korean dude was almost
50 you talk about Eric
[Laughter]
the secret to poker is drink the most
and talk the least don't do it maybe I
don't know today I feel it was less
about poker and more about just looking
around because every you could see
everyone's cards
Bobby literally would just show his
cards show other people and ask their
advice that's a definite no Bobby you've
had a great career thank you yeah I feel
like I don't know you guys as well and I
can't be mean do I begin do I get the
part it's a different I couldn't cut it
and stand up I tried no I did it for
maybe six months trip live I took one of
those classes yeah first time I did
stand-up I wore a suit and then our
class show was at like 5 o'clock on a
Tuesday and right before I went up this
was 15 years ago right before I went up
a girl comes in and was like hey I have
an audition Sarah Silverman was like hey
I have an audition and like made a tape
and I don't remember where it was in her
career right but then I went up
afterwards was like this is your first
click and I realize I shouldn't do
stand-up wait can we play sure this is
this is my favorite part about all all
this ad D is when somebody else wants to
tell a story and they really mean it
someone automatically goes can we just
play I mean I want to play and they want
to win money actually you don't need
money you just told me in the car that
you're like I don't deserve all this
money swimming and money I have so much
money
she goes I am so [ __ ] rich no you
didn't say that yeah that I'm saying is
that we get paid so much to do what we
do when you reach a level of success and
we don't deserve it if we really don't
it's too much money
it'll push a little Dominique Arden's
but I like that money okay you just wore
it why did it sound so cute like you
really it sounded like a button yeah I'm
so sorry about that okay burn one card
I'm not doing burn okay so ready yeah
we're ready
okay okay I'm gonna check I forgot to
I'll check okay Bobby
thanks bud no it just rushed things a
little bit
you production cards as the boys at
poker wrong but I'm fine with it
it's five not a lot no and then we go
around another one yeah you put two I
have to do it twice then now yeah no
we're just playing a new game but I'm
cool with it there's two footballs on
the field
I'll check - okay do one - pow get that
King get that baby dude you have three
kings yes I that's why he liked that you
did that yeah it's all everything about
this was wrong but in my favor
he could've never you could have brought
more you guys got more no but I didn't
have to steal money for no reason I said
yeah I don't I don't think any of these
people can Bluff which I said before
we're all like bluffers we're all these
big guy
we hyperbolized everything on stage and
yet for some reason in this world we're
terrible at hiding two numbers on a card
I guess it's like I guess you don't have
a good hand and then you make people
think you have a good hand or maybe you
have a good hand and you don't want
people to know how good it is
I'm terrible it yeah it's like you know
when I tell girls I have a big penis
you know and they don't buy it but they
go in all in anyway I tried to play a
mental game a couple times of like oh
I'll Bluff these [ __ ] out but even I
didn't trust my own Bluff and then I
would forget what I was bluffing about
yeah pokers all mental
there's about you know a collective ten
brain cells at that table and it showed
it definitely showed all right here we
go ready I'm ready
you're small okay thank you
thanks Brett thank you once I'm in so
I'm checking
I will check as well Bobby aren't play
there we are two chips burn one thrown
down again three check check check
well first I guess a call I'll go out
just um based on that look right there
you're welcome he is good the blacks
were five five let's raise five no no
okay so we're going in I don't know if
we have a winner or a loose cannon
yeah and now go friend then flip on so
now it's on Bobby because I'm out I'm
out boy called it grip tenon come on
grip come out all right let's go this is
a card that I need I'm gonna be so
[ __ ] yeah okay sure what do you have
for us
oh [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here Bobby
turn him turn him he doesn't have to
yeah he doesn't have he doesn't have to
turn not if she took it he doesn't have
to I mean
if you like some actual poker just
happened by I'm very competitive
I'm super competitive but like at things
I know I'm good at you know eating hot
dogs
I'm a very competitive person despite
the fact that I like to think I'm not
like in what way like I like to win you
know but I always lose hey can I get
more chips you paying somebody and I'll
give you I'll give you someone more cash
many wars happens yeah he does give me
some [ __ ] money I'll give you some
chips if I run out of money can I get by
no more chance of course you can okay
thank you
this should all go to charity for sure
this is so embarrassing I'm keeping it
you could buy stuff with a check
he's gonna be announcing Mary Poppins
stay ok alright I gotta stay that's
right the rights to happen again
now what is this Jesus Christ you guys
still races since I'm not in this one
we'll come on Jack do whatever you got
to do checking I'm worried about Bobby
you guys I'm very worried about him Oh
before we see another card yes such an
inner dialogue that came out so Santa it
also sounded right like a really good
friend to talk to my friend to yourself
it sounded very confident you did say
how much you've finally loved yourself
yeah yeah you're like love that was very
far as saying that sounded right
help you with the Jersey Mike's [ __ ]
chat I don't have any more gas in your
tank
[Laughter]
kimchee don't look at me when he does
that stuff Korean barbeque place look at
me look at him and get mad just be him
because somebody give me a diet coke I'm
parched my god where are we this is the
first bet for the last car got it
so now so yeah so now you two to stay in
yeah that's pretty pricey I think I will
risk it yes playing poker now we're
actually close to playing poker I'll do
two and raise five man oh but I'm saying
that makes me think you just want to see
the car exactly yes just play or oh now
I think let's go let's go
[Applause]
you guys good job no one knew the rules
yeah it's definitely important to know
the rules in poker it's probably one of
the main things you should know prior to
playing the game it's not important to
know the rules of Poker because there's
always someone who is overly
conscientious about other people's
mistakes so they'll correct you there is
no rules I don't even know how to spell
poker anymore
afterwards I knew before I don't know no
like I don't know how two grown men get
through life not knowing the rules of
Poker I think they should be ashamed of
themselves I think they should look
inside themselves and I blame their
fathers oh sorry I you know I don't
control the cards mess up here Bobby's
chewing I think we have to I think you
should get this part we have can we get
a room let's just get some let's see if
we're all quiet if we could actually
hear him chewing I kind of like it I
kind of like it too some are good some
are for sure I I've been on ASMR since
2010 like I am sound like he's going
down a fat girl it feels as good
I've heard that I've made what's a
skinny girl sound like smacking my
sternum Oh everything you're gonna say I
don't know okay so
nor on the arrow and so today let's see
the thank you burn one yo-yo
you can put all five down if you want to
pull it
check what is blue it was - - - I'm out
ok all right let's see it
stupid poker I'm ten tennis tube - this
is either a green or two blacks there
you go thank you I think that's called
splashing the pot I learned that from
rounders what does that mean when you
throw it when you throw your daughter
oh it's okay got it yeah a cannonball
and they'll last upon you good yeah
don't get your are you betting ten who's
asking okay no I'm it's just me Nikki
Bobby if this is a oh you that's
terrible
oh yeah somebody somebody poppy has a
straight cuz we got a nine all right so
wait who is it uh Nikki
twenty no my god why oh man you're gonna
have like two fours all right you have a
nice show it sort of a [ __ ] no I
wouldn't right wait wait yes
straight yeah oh yeah I just have two
kings higher straight than me I would
have lost to you anyway
I think you'd be really great at poker
you got to be a little bit of a dick I
think you gotta be a good actor you
gotta be smart you have to have focus
yeah I mean like you have to have a lot
of things that I'm guessing stand-up
comedians and actors don't actually have
that's why they're not poker the best
layer at the table was definitely
Santino because he knew what he was
doing of course it was yeah everybody
else sucked was embarrassing and Nikki
was playing for her and Bobby saw me so
I'll just give her that one too I mean
we were all better we're all bad the
fact that Andrew Santino is the best
says nothing who was the worst poker
player that's a hard one in this group
Bobby's by far the worst poker player
but the most fun person to have at a
poker table that's for sure I have a
look at my card just so I don't know
this information I'm all-in
[Laughter]
all right Bobby's all-in yeah what is
that
20 bucks how many Blues is that that's
those blues are worth two apiece so
that's 10 of those or 20 of the whites
or how you talk to him well he's my
little son green ones are worth what
Robert well I felt big time
so what do I do here so 5 here so you
need 15 more the only time is no 15 of
the white yeah then we do two of these
there there there there there Thank You
Bobby
yeah I'm out say to miss thank you Miss
bobbye's all in we're in let's see it
baby let's see it see it baby can I go
all in
this is 20 yeah it's 10 of those blues
everything you've got I got everything
in yep there we go okay well let's see
it doesn't matter yeah it does it does I
forget that this isn't real since it's
just you and me you're the producers of
the show every time you guys say 20 25
30 35 40 does is real Oh
$40 $40 that's real cash no way you can
buy 40 40 you know what it is don't play
dumb with me pal there's a little a lot
of anchor acting going there is a lot of
acting all right Nicki you want to go
more I would like to put you all in okay
let's go all in okay would you wanted
there you go straight why do you keep
getting straights how do you get there's
like I didn't have poker but I had poker
[Music]
let's get you saying that just with no
one talking go ahead
well that's poker a bumper off so that's
poker yes that was mine ooh sorry
sure just hear me out okay
yeah before we even see our two cards we
throw everything in the pot you guys
afraid I'm not much power if somebody
does sex to be brave but you know that
you're all-in is not as good as our
Islands
that means yours
[Laughter]
we're all in there so it all in there
man
this is feels yeah two cards from
anywhere this is the only pot I've ever
wanted
okay oh [ __ ]
now you're just putting three out right
now right [ __ ]
straight here show them one two three to
ten threes pair kings pair jacks oh
you're up Kings and nines Bobby's up
Bobby
nothing okay and they told me we divide
up this money I felt so good to go
all-in multiple times going all-in feels
so good
I mean I want to put it all the way in
you know if I if I could I'd you know
put the nuts in there but this is about
poker and going all-in is important when
you really want to show people the
thirst the weight of those two things
that you're holding on to and those two
things and the one thing that you've got
above it which is hoping that you'll win
or a penis reference Bobby somehow
convinced us by being adorable hey guys
do you want to just put it let's just
put on all our chips well I didn't spend
real money to get the chips so going
all-in when you have nothing was worth
anything there's no feeling behind it
but we all gave in to the peer pressure
and and Bobby you came out the winner
when I won at the end it felt unearned
but I got a doughnut so I'll take it the
doughnut was the most valuable thing on
the table and I lost it I bet it I could
have just ate it it was my doughnut well
that's poker